we interrupt your day to bring you a
story of exceptional stupidity Bill
Gates is it's kind of got intensive on
the internet lately and I just wanted to
talk about it because you know I know
I'm not gonna change the minds here
let's get real look at real this is a
YouTube video right but I thought I'd
highlight some of these comments because
I know that I wasn't aware how
widespread these ideas were you know and
it was until recently that my eyes were
kind of open and how many people believe
this stuff and it is shocking and it
makes you realize you know we've all
kind of had this thought in our head
that oh the world's becoming smarter
this generation is a more scientifically
literate than the generation before we
kind of have that idea in our head but I
have bad news for you guys
believe that I'm not sure that's true
what we'll find out today
okay so let me show you what made
inspired me to make this video okay I
was just looking up something something
something Bill Gates and I clicked on
the first video and let me just show you
the first thing is this Ellen clip or
whatever the first thing that I was
shocked
it's got like tons of dislikes and he's
just talking about finding a vaccine to
Cove at 19 and I went to the comment
section I said oh that's weird
and in the comment section like crazy
stuff I love these comments there's a
hope for Americans as long as you don't
fall for these turds yeah let's just use
vaccines from the guy who also wants to
depopulate the earth what could go wrong
mister eugenics population controlled
now wants to save he world with a
vaccines how ironic event 2 a 1 never
forget all right and that happens no
matter which Bill Gates clip you look at
just log into a browser and it just type
in Bill cakes look up any of the videos
the dislikes aren't saying the comments
aren't saying let's read some more
before we start we address some of this
stuff ok just came to see comments glad
to see people aren't falling for his
lies wwg one WGA every interview he does
he has a huge smile on his face would an
evil man
dude these are real think about like
this these are the top comments on
YouTube videos that are supposed to be
about Bill Gates like sharing
information about vaccines and stuff
instead the comments section has been
have been hijacked by conspiracy
theories and the dislike ratio shows
that like a substantial majority of
people watching this stuff totally
disagree with his model of the world so
I just wanted to die deep on what are
these people talking what why do they
say but why is Bill Gates been canceled
why have they cancelled him okay well it
comes from a few different sources the
first one is a TED talk that Bill Gates
did he did it in 2010 and they will cite
this this little clip of him where he
seemed to suggest that the world's gonna
be deep populated by vaccines here you
roll that clip first we've got
population now the world today has 6.8
billion people that's headed up to about
9 billion now if we do a really great
job on new vaccines health care
reproductive health services we could
lower that by perhaps 10 or 15 percent
and people take that for Bill Gates to
have admitted that the vaccine
conspiracy is really you know he's
secretly trying to kill people it's a
Freudian slip guys he admits it he
doesn't mean to what he admits it now if
we do a really great job on new vaccines
health care reproductive health services
we could lower that by perhaps 10 or 15
percent he's trying to lower population
now contrary to popular belief he didn't
just admit the new world's orders secret
conspiracy on a TED talk in fact he was
talking about a well known phenomena
when you lower people's mortality rates
they tend to have less kids when people
are sure that their kids aren't going to
die in childbirth from preventable
infectious diseases they tend to have
less kids and this is a well-known thing
he wrote about before this 2010 this
2010 youtube video i think he wrote
about it in his 2009 gaits letter so a
year before he talked about this
learning about this interesting fact
when you improve people's health the
number of kids they have goes down and
so he's just talking about that so he's
incentive eyes I mean
if you think even if you think that Bill
Gates secretly wants to lower the
population literally what you have to
admit is that based on data
the best way for Bill Gates to be a
eugenicist as you guys half the internet
basically thinks he is is by improving
public health that's like literally the
conclusion that you come to is that if
you want to lower population you improve
health right that's like the irony
behind it all the counterintuitive side
of it so I don't know who cares nobody
believes this stuff anyway everybody's
made up their mind literally all the
comments in in this video I guarantee
are either gonna be people already
agreeing with me or already disagreeing
with me there's going to be not a single
person who changes their mind from this
for you and I'm okay with that because
that's not really the point the other
thing that Bill Gates has been cancelled
over is this event 201 okay so this is
like the dumbest thing ever to but you
know why not why not get into it
okay so event to a-1 was a pandemic
preparedness like summit that they did
before the corona virus was ever
discovered okay now in a event till one
happened to be like three months or two
months before that the outbreak started
in China and it was a led in part by
Bill Gates and so the pandemic global
pandemic exercise was they suggested a
hypothetical pandemic scenario and then
they like said like oh what would we do
if this happened so we can try to get
ready well the the virus they happen to
choose was a corona virus a new corona
virus spread silently within hers and so
people said hey Bill Gates of us to
predict not not only did he predict the
virus he had something to do with it
because you know how could you guess
that there it's gonna be a corona virus
how can you guess that it's going to be
a corona virus with flu-like symptoms
this is a conspiracy they accidentally
left his website public you know because
because obviously the new world order
wouldn't want us finding out about this
right in actuality you find out that
literally people have been talking about
their big
pandemic for years hey guys I just
wanted to jump in here because what I
was about to say was really boring and
dumb and it just reminds me that I
haven't learned my lesson that nobody
cares about facts so let's just do a
thought experiment for fun instead of
trying to use facts let's just do it a
thought experiment here are a bunch of
people who are also are just part of the
New World Order that you guys should
know about because if you think they're
predicting a pandemic in a world where
we were not ready for pandemic is
predicting the pandemic then well people
knew that if there was gonna be a
pandemic it would likely be an RNA virus
so either if you're thinking about like
what's the next pandemic it's not that
much of a shock to pick coronavirus
because either it's gonna be influenza
or coronavirus some kind of corona virus
that's what they were guessing so if you
think it's a big shock that they
predicted it's gonna be a corona virus
they had a 1 and 2 shot of being right
also there are a bunch of other people
who so-called predicted it including a
psychic this girl Sylvia Browne was said
to predict that it was going to be a
corona virus for the next pandemic in a
book in 2008 so if you're mad at Billy
Boy from predicting it three months
before try predicting it 10 12 12 years
before I think Sylvia Browne is the real
one we have to worry about it's a little
update that I thought was funny if you
go to The Ellen Show now they had to
shut down the comments because they were
getting so brutal against Billy Boy and
it's it's kind of sad because he spent
his whole life trying to give money away
we definitely don't deserve Bill Gates
I mean he's given so far a total of 21
billion dollars to charity through his
foundation and we hate him for it so
that's what you get you know that's what
you get for spending 5 billion dollars
on infectious disease control it's what
you get for trying to help malaria it's
what you get for trying giving a billion
dollars to tuberculosis you know we
don't want you we don't want you Bill
Gates you know we don't want your your
money and
and your help because you're just part
of a new world order clearly I do just
let's let's take a good look at the the
comment section again that they're
coming in hot coming in hot for Billy
Billy did not do himself any favors
I mean running a vid 2a1 how dare you
try to get ready for a pandemic that
you've been warning the world about for
years how dare you Bill how dare you try
to improve the public health of
third-world countries how dare you how
date we don't want your help
let's look at these comments dude it's
crazy judging by the comments here old
Billy Boy isn't popular I didn't realize
that be Gates was a doctor scientist be
Gates is nothing but a man who says one
thing and thinks enough gigs up gig is
up
everything everyone know about Billy Boy
we didn't simulate this we didn't
practice yes they did event to a one
last October he's talking about the
government the world the world will not
be destroyed by those who do evil but by
those who watch them without doing
anything including my pathetic self yes
me sad how is he doing evil literally
look at this man look at how many
millions of dollars this guy has given
to thinks including which I'm shocked
anyone would try to get him on this
people say like why isn't he giving two
toilets and food to people in Africa
that's why what they really need why is
he just giving vaccines he's also giving
those things he spent three hundred
million dollars on sanitation and three
hundred million dollars on basic
nutrition and four hundred million
dollars on health care but you know what
Bill we don't want your money
we don't want your time we don't want
your efforts because we'd rather listen
to David Icke we'd rather listen to
Peter say we'd rather listen to people
who tell us
that medicine is bad for us and I think
if we follow their advice as we could
lower that by perhaps 10 or 15 percent
[Music]
but never sure the truck
[Music]